there's a new Game of Thrones spin-off
show in development about aegon's
Conquest the story of how the tarians
first took over Westeros there have been
previous attempts to make an agon's
Conquest show but now it's in
development with a new writer so there
are now at least six Game of Thrones
spin-off shows in development House of
the Dragon season 2 will Air this year a
KN of the Seven Kingdoms has been
greenlit about the adventures of dunk
and egg there's an animated show in
development about the Voyages of the sea
snake and there are two more animated
projects in development one of these
might be the Golden Empire about yet the
Game of Thrones version of China there
was a sequel show about Jon Snow in
development led by kit Harrington but
it's not clear if that show is still
being made there was also a show about
neria in development about an ancient
Eastern princess finally there's a stage
show about the Tony of harrenhal being
made which might open late this year
we've made videos about most of these
stories on our YouTube channel alt shift
X